hi everybody thank you for watching my
talk this is going to be all about
parallel processing in python really
all about the landscape of tools that
exist today for parallel distributed
cluster computing
all of those things things are moving
really really quickly these days
so hopefully i can at least catch you up
on where we are now uh but then likely
this talk is going to be out of date in
six months so
i'm not going to go super in-depth on
any tool but i'll be giving links and
some
some resources so if you want to grab
the slides you can kind of follow along
there and click on the links
and then one thing i'll say is that all
the opinions that i kind of talk about
of these different tools are
my own my name is aaron i work for
saturn cloud and really my job there is
to ensure that data scientists can do
their work in the fastest way possible
using the best tools
either the tools that they kind of
already know and love or help them along
with tools that they don't
already don't yet know um and i actually
gave a talk
at pi data miami in 2019 that feels like
forever ago and it's funny because that
talk was actually all about how your
data fits in ram and you don't need
cluster computing
so i had done a lot of work in the past
with spark more from the data
engineering side and then i kind of
always did my machine learning and data
science in the pi data ecosystem like
scikit-learn and pandas and such
um and i was talking all about there how
you can really take advantage of your
laptop but then also do kind of
parallel processing just on your single
machine and this
feels like a natural kind of evolution
onto waze
um onto like when you actually need
cluster computing what are the right
tools to choose
for that job so i work for saturn cloud
full disclosure we are we are a
commercial offering centered around a
couple of the tools that i'm going to be
talking
about uh in my talk so i'm going to try
to give like kind of an unbiased and
fair shake of the stuff but
inevitably it's going to be a little bit
biased and kind of all of these kinds of
talks are
a little bit biased anyway i'm just
telling you what my bias is
um so saturn cloud itself is an
end-to-end data science and machine
learning platform on the cloud
we just make it easy for data science
teams and data scientists to kind of get
going in
python and then get going scaling to
clusters with desk and
gpus with rapids and things like that
so first this is just like why do we
need parallel computing right
we have this great awesome pi data stack
where we can do a lot of things but a
lot of these tools were historically
built for single core
uh in memory type work and that's really
where a lot of these challenges come
from
so like you know if you're ready to kind
of analyze your data and get going
um you know you can use those tools
fairly well um and
if you've seen any of my talks before i
am reusing the memes here so apologies
it's kind of hard to find
good memes these days you know but
anyway you might run out of memory
right that's the first thing it's like
okay well now i need a cluster i need a
bigger machine because i'm out of memory
or if you do get enough memory your
computing just takes forever
um and then you're either stuck waiting
or now you have to find another solution
and then you end up feeling like this so
the entire idea is that
from my talk is so that you don't feel
like this and you feel empowered
to choose the right tool over what you
might need to do
so when would you need parallel
processing similar to what we just went
through is when you have a lot of data
or you have a lot of computations that
you need to run or both
so i do want to caveat this and this
relates a little bit to my previous paid
in miami talk is that
you shouldn't do cluster computing or
parallel computing unless you have to
if everything works just fine on your
laptop in pandas numpy and that kind of
world
stay there there's no reason to learn
something else if you start to hit
boundary if you start to kind of hit the
walls of that
um you can actually use most of these
tools that i'm talking about today
on your laptop or on a single machine
it's a lot less infrastructure to manage
than a cluster
same way you can kind of bump that up to
a pretty big machine in the cloud
still on a single machine and then
really when you need to take advantage
of a lot of resources you can then do a
cluster
on the cloud and then you can kind of
mix and match depending on specific
workloads you can do it on a cluster
here and do it on a single machine there
so this is really what we're talking
about and try to say this five times
fast
python packages for parallel processing
i can barely even say it
but that's what we're going through
today uh a few different packages
i'll start with just kind of giving you
an overview of the land in the world
that we're kind of coming from
is again we're starting from this kind
of pi data single machine
type work these are just kind of
representative packages for the types of
workloads you might do so data frames
arrays
machine learning and deep learning not
an exhaustive list
but kind of in parallel there's this
other world that has been built up over
the last 10 20 years
is this kind of big data world that was
really more of like data engineers
etl type jobs that kind of came out of
the hadoop ecosystem so there's
a few tools there we're really not going
to focus on a lot of them except for
spark
but the idea is now that these two
worlds are coalescing where we need
scientific computing like an intense
data science stuff
on large amounts of data so we're kind
of putting these two things together
and that's where some of the tools that
i'm talking about uh fit in
we're gonna focus specifically on these
three tools spark ray and das for like
the parallel computing and i'm going to
give you the stories on each of them and
kind of compare and contrast
on the bottom row here rapids mode in vx
and mars they're kind of
some honorable mentions i'm going to
talk a lot about rapids because it's
actually very relevant
with these tools but in itself it's not
technically a parallel computing tool
um and then mode nvx i'll mention real
quick a mars is something that's super
super new i'm not even really going to
focus on but at least wanted to
throw the logo on there to show that
there's like a lot of players
in this space but hopefully we can kind
of simplify that here
so when it comes to actually choosing
the tool and really this is especially
when you're
choosing this for like enterprise
adoption there's a lot of considerations
when you're picking an open source
project or all these things you might
want to know because it'll help inform
the type of experience you might get
when you're using these tools so
um here are all the points i'm not gonna
talk about each of them because i'm
gonna have a slide kind of dedicated to
them
but basically it's like why was the tool
created what community was it created
for
how popular is it now how well
maintained is it
how can you kind of dive into the tool
itself and check out the code
and then the hardest part with a lot of
this is really the deployment piece
when you have to deal with clusters and
machines and infrastructure and all that
stuff
and that's where commercial offerings a
lot of the times come in they do manage
services
and then we'll i'll kind of introduce
all of these tools individually for
these considerations and i'm going to
flip it
and i'm going to go based on work loader
capabilities so i'll say
data frames what's available arrays
what's available machine learning deep
learning
that kind of stuff and it's all about
what's built into the tool directly and
then what kind of ecosystem is built
around the tool
to enable a lot of different workloads
because again that helps show like how
mature and how stable the tool itself is
so i took a few of these points uh from
this talk from
up heidi in new york city last year from
eric dill and he gave a great talk
kind of doing something similar
specifically for spark versus desk
and rapid so i'm kind of pulling in
right here i'm pulling in some of my own
opinions and then also giving it a quick
update because
that talk was a year ago so again this
makes the space moves really fast so
it's a bit outdated now
okay spark um basically spark again was
born out of the hadoop ecosystem in that
hadoop world
it's a distributed computing platform
based on the concept of mapreduce
and it was again created for like
large-scale analytics etl things that
data engineers
would do and it's the oldest tool that
we're talking about
um here when it comes to desk
desk is a again distributed computing
tool these all are
but it's based on task scheduling of
low-level task scheduling so it's a
different
paradigm than mapreduce where you kind
of map over a list and then kind of
reduce individually
this is actually parallelizing
individual units of work
and the reason this was created was
specifically to scale
python code and python packages it was
born and created at anaconda
specifically so that you can ex so that
people could accelerate python packages
so
that community that's been built up
around it you'll see the difference
there
so specifically for python
ray is here actually came out of the
same research lab that created spark i
think they changed names but it's the
same lab a lot of
some of the same professors and people
involved um the low level of kind of
task paradigm is very similar to task
it introduced the concept of actors
which i'll get into
but desk and ray there's actually this
thread on github where the the creators
will actually talk about the differences
the main things might were that actor
thing
and then just some nuances of how the
task scheduling works for each of these
tools
but i believe that rey was originally
and initially built for like
distributing deep learning applications
and i put that in a question mark only
because i am the least familiar with ray
of all these tools just letting you know
because i think i've been
the deep learning is the community i've
been kind of less connected to as
opposed to like
data engineering spark and data science
with desk and things like that
okay so here's a slide of just all of
them so you can kind of see how the
logos and
see the whole story for all of them i do
need to mention one other tool and
that's rapids
because rapids itself the core of what
rapids is is pushing
data science workloads to the gpu so
it's packages it's packages for data
frames
arrays machine learning where now
instead of executing on cpus like all
the other packages do
it'll actually execute way way faster on
a gpu and it's really exciting so i
would definitely check out rapids
it's a cool package it's really
mind-blowing some of the performance
speed ups you get
um it's newer it's created at nvidia it
is an open source project and there's a
large dev team support from nvidia
but the key here when we're talking
about parallel computing is that das has
a native
i'm sorry rapids has a native das
integration to actually execute on
multiple gpus because
gpus have a lot less ram than main
memory so you need to kind of scale out
when your data gets bigger
but it integrates really well with the
python ecosystem it's it's one of those
consequences of das
being python native and built for python
it was kind of the inevitable choice to
scale rapids so when i'm talking about
das
think about rapids as kind of coming
alongside with desk as well in a lot of
these places
[Music]
if you want more about das another pi
data talk keith cross is
one of the maintainers of rapids uh
specifically the data frame package i
believe
and he gave an awesome talk on just like
all things rapids if you don't know
anything about it
watch this talk you'll be convinced the
gpus are the future and you'll be
convinced that
uh rapids is a great package and desk
with it is is good too
and but again it's already outdated so
there's a lot of new developments that
have happened in the last year but i'm
not going to focus a lot on that on
rapids specifically
so when it comes to languages i took
these screenshots straight from the
github
repos of all these projects but the main
idea here is that spark was built in
scala it's a jvm language so
that kind of like reflects itself and
when you get errors and that you get
these kind of weird java stack traces
and when you're trying to debug it or
when you try to
contribute to it you're going to have to
write in scala so given this is a
pi data python audience i'm assuming
that might be kind of a big hurdle for a
lot of people here
to ask you can see here is 100 or 99.9
i don't know what the other point one is
python built in python
api for python ray its main api
is python and it integrates with a lot
of the python packages there is some
code there kind of built in c
plus and some other things so might be a
little bit more kind of
hurdle to contribute if you want to uh
popularity
so i don't want to look at github stars
but i don't think that's the best metric
um so when i think of like how popular
is a person
i'll go check their twitter or their
instagram how many followers do they
have so maybe the same thing works for
open source python packages i don't know
well
um so spark here has like 30 000
followers again it's the oldest tool
you see this account was created four
years before desk desk has around 6 000
and ray has like 1400 so that kind of
gives you
some relative idea of popularity maybe
but i have a better more scientific
metric here
which is pi pi stats so this is pip
install
package like how many times does that
happen so it doesn't necessarily mean
a net new user or a specific individual
it probably means more of
automated jobs doing pip installs like
daily or on some other schedule
but it still gives a good relative
comparison of how popular to
the tool is because if a tool is kind of
being used daily for a job that's always
pip installing then
it's probably being used a lot and it's
probably popular so
spark here has the most at seven million
desk at almost one and a half and then
raise uh
there at 200 000. so this is as of
october 2020 but hopefully that gives
you
again like a relative idea of the
popularity
[Music]
and then spark and dash specifically
were part of the python developer survey
in 2019 that jetbrains did
and this is of all python users so not
even just data science like web
devops like all python users 13 of them
said they use spark
and then 5 of them said they use desk
which shows that there's like a big
group of people actually using these
tools like five percent of
all python users using desk is like a
good significant
number array wasn't on the survey
probably again because it's like newer
and not as popular
maybe it'll be in a future one
okay so as far as native capabilities
there's there's a lot here going on but
the idea is like you know if there's a
specific meaning that you do and that
you focus on or like a handful of them
this list might give you a good idea of
like which tool might be the right thing
to choose so
for spark i say the most popular
capabilities of spark are the data
frames and sql
and then i think some people use the
machine learning i kind of recommend
not to um and then dask is
all the way from like low level task
parallelization you can parallelize just
like arbitrary code
all the way up to data frames arrays
and machine learning and then rey you
can kind of see the difference on the
different kind of applications that rey
has been focused on is really a lot
around deep learning
reinforcement learning distributing deep
learning training
model serving and things like that and
then the kind of custom api is similar
again to desk
where you can do individual tasks and
then it introduced this kind of
actors api and so the native
capabilities can be a little bit fuzzy
because again when it comes to like the
ecosystem
things can be built on top of these
tools and built with them and i think
that's really
even a more compelling type of thing to
look at so here's the ecosystem
spark itself is mostly an all-in-one
package
all-in-one tool part of partially
because of the way that it was built is
kind of internals
and partially just kind of that's how
it's been um they have
been doing some work to kind of pull in
more pi data workloads and kind of
python support into spark
but it does feel a little bolted on like
in easier to find functions and kind of
like
extraneous packages and i think even the
extra boost had to be forked for it to
work properly
um so it doesn't have really a lot of
ecosystem the same way that like pi data
normally does with a lot of packages
interacting
das definitely has the biggest ecosystem
here because it was built
specifically to support parallelization
for a lot of packages so
like rapids and scikit-learn and like a
bunch of other tools and and what's with
especially with desk is tools were built
like
specifically like where their core
functionality is built
with desk tools like rapids and prefect
um or
an x-array or like desk is really really
core to how that tool works and
it's parallelization ray you'll see here
like pytorch tensorflow are big ones
again because of the deep learning
and then like a couple other tools it's
it's integrations are newer actually
this link if you click on it and you
look at some of the github pages for
those integrations they're almost
some of them are just like a week or a
few days old and that kind of shows how
quickly
rey is moving and like some of the new
stuff that's happening right now but it
is still really new and i think not as
mature of an ecosystem
das is listed there and the desk and
write integration is specifically
for doing using raise scheduler to
schedule task tasks
um that's pretty much it i'm not sure
that anybody uses that and i'm not sure
of the benefits of it i haven't been
able to use that myself so i can't
really speak to it
[Music]
okay so when it comes to deployment like
i said this is the hardest
thing generally with these tools um but
it kind of the options kind of reflect
again when they were born so like spark
hadoop and yarn
spark was born out of hadoop and so
that's kind of one of the main
deployment options
whereas with das it was built to support
a lot of different workloads and a lot
of like scientific and academic stuff
so there's like hpc support there but
then also like
native cloud integrations where you can
just put in your aws credentials and
then like run a script and then it'll
launch a dash cluster
and then ray again being newer and being
more cloud focused
most of their deployment options are
like strictly just straight cloud
but then like what about the pain factor
right so it's not just like how can you
deploy but like how hard is it to manage
and
and all that stuff um with spark there's
like a lot of more things to get working
a lot more
configuration you have to do um a lot
more knobs you have to tweak
das is pure python again so that might
be a little bit easier to work with
um and then ray i don't have a lot of
information sharing that because i
haven't done like a whole lot of
deployment
with ray but it seems like the code that
they built in there is kind of made for
easy deployments
but this is where kind of commercial
offerings really come to the
conversation because deployment's hard
so then companies are out here
giving you managed services for these
tools when it comes to spark there are a
lot of managed services
out there databricks is probably one of
the leading ones where they kind of have
like
easy to easy to manage spark clusters
you can kind of launch them and run your
spark code clouds themselves also have
native hadoop and spark offerings that i
think a lot of people use i've used emr
and databricks both myself
and you know microsoft and google have
offerings there um dasc is
is was originally again born out of
anaconda so there's a support
perspective from there but anaconda
doesn't do any like managed desk
um what's cool is that within the last
year or two
there's now packages or i'm sorry now
companies out here to do managed
desk clusters so one of them is the
company that i work for saturn cloud
and quote as well does that uh ray the
only company really in the space of ray
right now
is any scale i think they just opened up
a private beta like
a week or two ago like really recently
and they seem to be driving forward a
lot of like the ray road map
and all those things but the main
takeaway from this slide is that spark
is mature has a lot of offerings
das is picking up a lot of traction
commercially which is which is a great
sign
and which means that there's like a lot
of there's options now and there's like
support and you know that like companies
are
really caring about it and it feels a
lot like the beginning of like the
hadoop world when companies like
cloudera and hortonworks and such came
out
and then ray has like any scale kind of
pushing it forward right now
but it is still like the newest okay so
we're going to take a quick breather
here
because i know i threw a lot of
information at you um so hopefully you
can digest some of that look at the
slides and then we're going to pivot
this now
we're going to look at capabilities and
workloads and then what tools might be
the best things to choose
for these different workloads okay
capabilities the ones we're specifically
going to focus on are these
specific these are really like data
science and machine learning focused
type workloads and i'll talk about all
of these different ones
so arrays is probably the the simplest
choice or the easiest kind of thing to
navigate because
if you're doing multi-dimensional arrays
and you need parallel computing for it
das is your choice that's the only like
definitive thing i'm going to say in
this whole presentation
is that if you need multi-dimensional
arrays use das it's really the only
option out there and it is a very good
one not just it's the only one
and then a with coupe i which is like a
gpu enabled one das integrates with that
so you can do like gpu
accelerated arrays with spark the way
that it's built it's just really not
possible to do multi-dimensional arrays
and ray it's probably technically
possible to like
customize something with the task
interface but it's probably more work
than it's worth
and so desk is really the choice here
data frames is the opposite now
data frames is like the really really
complicated not complicated but really
really crowded
side of the parallel computing world we
have spark which has its own
data frame api it doesn't mirror pandas
and then the rest of these tools
are really all kind of like mirroring
pandas or pandas based apis
and things like that so das has a data
frame which kind of parallelizes pandas
data frames and it handles the
orchestration there
koalas is a package that's a panda's
front end
for spark so all of your stuff that's
happening is executing on spark on a
spark cluster it's going to scala and
like all that stuff so you need a spark
cluster and everything
but you're writing code that looks like
pandas mode in
is similar except it's for a ray or a
das
backend so moden's goal is where you can
just switch your import pandas to import
mode in
and then it'll parallelize that to array
or das cluster which you kind of specify
vex here is like an honorable mention i
have an asterisk because it's not a
parallel computing tool
it's an out of core data frame tool so
but people mention it a lot when they're
talking about like accelerating data
frames so
vex is a way for you to analyze data
sets that are larger than fit into
memory
on your laptop or single machine but
it's not a parallel processing tool
and then rapids comes in for the gpu
accelerated data frames
and then you can parallelize that with
the native das integration and kind of
get a lot of speed ups
ibis here is a good thing to mention too
which is not pandas based it's a data
frame api that's more sql
kind of focused but it's meant to have
like different interchangeable backends
so like
postgres or snowflake or anything like
that but your code is like
a data frame api um
so there's a lot of choices here right
um i think
my kind of recommendation is that your
data frame isn't necessarily the driving
choice for the tool
you kind of want to think about some of
the other things that you're doing like
the machine learning and scientific
computing
if you're only doing data frames and you
just have like a csv that's a little bit
bigger than your laptop
you have more flexibility you can kind
of choose whichever one you're more
comfortable with
but you really need to think about the
ecosystem and the other things that
you're going to do beyond the data
frames
when choosing a tool if you want to know
more about this whole data frame world
though
you can check out this talk from mark
garcia he's a pandas core developer in
ibis as well
he gave a great talk at a pi data meetup
just recently kind of
going more in depth to this whole kind
of messy data frame ecosystem
okay so so i said that your decision
should be driven
more by more than just data frames like
if you're doing a raise you're going to
want to ask
and then we'll talk here about machine
learning and deep learning specifically
so
machine learning there's more than just
training
a model on a giant data set it's
about like what are you actually doing
in that case so like a lot of the times
and my last pi day to talk was about
this is a lot of times you just can
sample your data set and use
scikit-learn and you should do that
if you can do that and it's accurate do
that there's no reason to like
use more data when it's not necessary so
and then if you have that trained model
when you're doing parallel computing
you're probably doing like parallel like
batch inference
or you're probably doing some sort of
hyper parameter tuning or ensembling and
that's when it gets
really interesting and that's when you
probably will need a lot of these tools
but there is
still the concept of distributed
training like in case you really do need
to use those large data sets and so
spark has a lot of algorithms
built in for distributed training das
and rapids
also do and desk and rapids have native
interoperability with scikit-learn so
you can use a scikit-learn pipeline
with a das ml model and that way you're
not kind of having to relearn again like
a new tool where a sparx ml
package is a completely new api that you
would have to learn
um when it comes to batch inference
these all these tools can really do
batch inference because you're just
wrapping
up model that predict in some sort of
cluster kind of
orchestration type thing so with dash
delayed or even like a spark udf or
something like that you can
you can pretty much get away with batch
inference pretty easily with all of
these tools
um but uh das does have like a native
parallel postfit class where you can
um like use passing your scikit-learn
model but then kind of
use that same api to do like batch
inference across the cluster hyper
parameter tuning is where this gets
really interesting is when you need to
train a bunch of models maybe the data
itself is pretty small but you need to
do
a lot of training rey desk and rapids
all have
offerings around hyper parameter tuning
that you can kind of take a look at more
um and stay tuned i'm probably going to
be working on some sort of blog post
with saturn about like specifically like
which
algorithms are available for distributed
training versus hyper parameter tuning
versus batch inference and we'll go into
a lot more details specifically on which
tool
has which but as far as the distributed
training um
spark and dash and rapids cover pretty
like very similar algorithms
whereas rey doesn't really have a lot of
distributed training specifically for
machine learning their focus is more on
deep learning like i'll show you
so so actually one thing that you'll see
in all of these tools
have a job lib back end so what this
means is scikit learn
has this api that uses job lib for
managing like parallel training so
scikit-learn does parallel training like
through a grid search
or random force but built-in is just on
a single machine it'll use all the cores
in your machine
all of these tools dasgrain spark all
have interfaces for a job
back-end which will just take that
training and now parallelize it across
your cluster
the key here though is that your data
has to still fit in memory of your
client machine it's not like a truly
distributed
training where you can kind of pull in
chunks of the data automatically and
then distribute from there because
you'll have to actually pull it through
scikit-learn and then it gets
distributed out so this is useful for
those like big compute scenarios
where you kind of just need to
distribute a lot of things like a random
forest or like a grid search
um that's kind of how you would and
here's just examples of how you might do
it
it's all very similar you just tell it a
different
job led back in with the with the
context manager
okay so when it comes to now tree
ensembles and this is
specifically like xg boost is mostly
what i'm focusing on and then as well
light gbm xg boost has ways
to parallelize model training with all
of these tools
uh spark it's a little clunkier i think
this
xg boost 4j spark package i've tried to
get it working with python i haven't had
a lot of success
our rapids as well has some stuff
integrated with spark to do extra boost
but
i think it's required some like private
forks to get it working so
it's not like a super native integration
um
desk itself actually the xgboost package
if you go to the extra boost
docs you'll see a section about how to
parallelize training with das
specifically so there's a really really
tight native integration there
um there is a das light gbm package and
we at saturn actually
one of my colleagues there is actually
working specifically on putting that
natively into the light gpm package
where you can use das directly from
there
you can also do dash and rapids for the
gpu computing like shown
there which is again native to the xg
boost package so
das is really really tightly coupled
into that ray has a super new package
called
xgboostray to do like the
parallelization
with ray um i again it's super new so i
haven't had a chance to use it but maybe
that's something to watch out for if
you're interested in that
[Music]
okay so when it comes to deep learning
here i think again ray i think was
initially built for a lot of this kind
of deep learning type work
so you'll see more of its high level
interfaces
focusing on that so like distributed
training with pytorch and tensorflow
hyper parameter tuning and reinforcement
learning you can kind of check out those
different libraries
and see how ray works with that um das
the distributed like
inference is a pretty straightforward
exercise with desk we're actually
working on a blog post that saturn
uh to kind of illustrating that with
tensorflow or pi torch
um because you kind of just can wrap in
a delayed function
doing inference and training is also
possible
there aren't currently native
integrations with pytorch and tension
flow for das
we are at saturn specifically working on
one uh
we're working on pi torch first um so
kind of you know stay tuned on that
we're
working on that kind of native
integration but das does
integrate from the more of the inference
hyper parameter tuning side not the
training
with the kind of scikit-learn api
packages
around pytorch and tensorflow so scorch
and psycaris
if you use those tools it's actually
pretty straightforward and there's
desk docs for how to actually
parallelize across a cluster of gpus
that's probably mostly for hyper
parameter tuning or maybe inference if
you're using the scikit-learn apis with
these
with these deep learning tools
okay so that was a lot of stuff so i'm
hoping i at least gave you a little bit
of insight onto like
the different workloads and which tools
might use but then maybe
you know maybe you're like me when i go
to talk like this i want somebody to
just tell me what to choose like just
tell me which package i need to use
please
like there's too many choices well i'm
not going to completely do that
i'm just going to kind of give you some
candid opinions on each of the tools and
hopefully that can kind of help you
and if you want to kind of talk about
this more find me in gather town or like
hit me up on twitter or something and we
can chat more about this
so uh first spark i'm just gonna kind of
give you my opinions
i think if you're doing stuff like
already in spark
in the kind of just data engineering
world of
mostly sql-esque type work and
transformations
and you're not really doing a lot of
machine learning you're not doing a lot
of data science
specifically spark is probably still
like a good choice for that if you're
if you're doing that and especially if
you already use it it can be challenging
with debugging scala
um and cluster management and deployment
so there's are still reasons that i
would think even if you're only doing
that stuff you might want to consider
another tool but if you're doing like a
lot of machine learning
if you're doing deep learning scientific
computing if you have a lot of code
already written
in the pi data ecosystem spark is
probably not the best choice for that
because you're going to have to rewrite
a lot of your stuff you're going to have
to deal with the jvm
and probably some things that you might
want to do won't even be possible
okay so desk um if you don't even like
want to believe me there's a
there's a great desk article about
really like why an institution
should adopt ask and the scenarios and
the reasons to do that
there's a there's a really great article
if you want to read that
why you would use it is because of its
large ecosystem of packages
because it's python native it's built
for data science
machine learning scientific computing
like i mentioned
if you're doing multi-dimensional arrays
and you need to scale them
you're going to want to use das x-ray is
like a fantastic and awesome package
in that world but it also has a super
flexible low-level api for you to just
parallelize
kind of arbitrary python code and that's
the core of what desk is
and there's a lot of deployment options
from like just desk itself
on hpc or clouds or different things and
there's commercial support for that too
reasons that you might not use desk
maybe if all of your work is like
pure sql type transformations um
you might be better off using another
tool and then maybe not even spark in
that case you might be better off
using like a database like snowflake or
some other type of like pure sequel
uh work so ray so why
rey i'd say ray was built up a lot for a
lot of deep learning features
um so if that's like if that's all that
you do and like all that you're
interested in for cluster computing
ray might be something that you would
want to look at um
and the low level api like if you really
want like a low level actor api
you can use ray um otherwise the task
api again is like really similar to desk
and desk i think still has like a bigger
ecosystem
um and why would you not use rey i think
just because it's still
pretty new like there is a lot of
momentum that like any scale is bringing
a lot around it a lot of stuff happening
um
there's still only like one commercial
player which means that you know they're
kind of only
driving all of rey um and so it's just
like newer
um and if that's something where you're
kind of fine with you want to kind of
like
play around with it and try it you can
definitely check it out but
um again i'm a little biased i'm
probably going to recommend desk for a
lot of your workloads
so would you use more than one that
might be a question to think about when
you're thinking about all these tools
um i would say you're probably not going
to use more than one in the same script
or the same job
you could technically use more than one
in the same cluster
because like if like with yarn or
something they kind of all support yarn
or maybe
but or like a cloud provider i don't
think there's really a reason to like
run desk and spark or desk and rain and
all those things on the same cluster
but across an enterprise i could see
potentially
uh like an organization using more than
one tool like if they have a lot of data
engineering already built up in spark
but they now need to parallelize a lot
of their data science
they might use desk or like deep
learning stuff with ray
um again i i think the most flexible
option for like smaller teams and
organizations that kind of need to do a
ride for a wide variety of work
uh is desk and then really if you want
to do like gpu acceleration with rapids
das is really your choice um because
that has really the best
uh integration with it there
and that's it so again thank you for
watching i know i threw a lot of
information at you
so if you want a little bit to know talk
a little bit more chat a little bit more
you have specific workloads that you're
thinking about you need to parallelize
i would love to talk with you if you
find me in gathered town or
send me an email find me on twitter we
also do have a
slack community for saturn cloud so you
can kind of jump in there
find me or like just post on the chat
it's you know open community talking
about all things python and parallel
computing and everything
um and if you do want to try saturn
cloud if like you're really kind of
convinced about da ask and rapids
we have like a free hosted oh we have a
hosted product where you can get a free
trial on there and it's kind of just
like a pay as you go thing
you don't even have to install it in any
of your clouds or anything like that
or if you need an enterprise solution we
do have one that you can install
into your kind of cloud account but um
again thank you for watching i hope this
didn't create more
confusion it might have but hopefully at
least you are now familiar with the
names of the packages
what they do what they don't do and then
that'll help drive your future research
and adoption but again reach out if you
have any questions
thank you